de la virgen de la Paix oxygen premiere
sur un premier album de mu nu d2l Cyndi Lauper tu as
monté en flèche dans le classement américain en 1984, ce qui
est si inhabituel avec quatre singles dans le
premier c'est très rare pour les femmes et en
plus tu dois le regarder de cette façon
il y a plus et  on est plus nombreux on va
mieux et tu sais qu'ils ne nous ont plus mis
dans les rizières donc tu sais
on va mieux on essaie de trouver des
explications avant tout tu es un bon
artiste bien sûr tu as eu du bon  matériel
mais tu as un look magnifique maintenant est-
ce parce que tu travaillais dans un nouveau
magasin ouais j'étais pointu j'ai travaillé dans
le magasin de mon amie et maintenant je la traîne avec moi
partout où elle a conçu cette robe je
sais qu'elle l'a sortie d'un rouge  pile je
pense oui alors elle elle s'occupe de Vintage
Rose et
elle a trouvé cette robe je l'adore tu sais
c'est comme une nouveauté avant d'avoir
le bon comportement avec les médias tu
sais très bien se comporter devant
les médias maintenant n'  t vous ouais bien vous
savez je sais juste la bonne chose non je
je ne sais pas j'essaie juste de parler aux
gens je parle à n'importe qui
une autre chose est que vous êtes l'un des
artistes de la première année vidéo que vous connaissez
très bien pour gérer vos clips vidéo
maintenant bien je m'améliore avec eux et
ceci comme cette vidéo, j'ai co-réalisé celle-
ci avec Scott Calvert et je pense
que la vidéo est un endroit formidable comme un excellent
terrain d'entraînement avant de faire un film et
il est très difficile de trouver un
réalisateur vidéo qui ne veut pas faire un
film  maintenant ils ont fait un film je préfère
juste tu sais si tu vas faire un film
- un film si tu peux faire une vidéo tu fais une
vidéo tu sais que ton manager est ton
petit ami - maintenant tu ne perds pas de temps je
veux dire non  ce n'est plus mon petit ami oh
c'est mon manager et mon meilleur ami
ne l'a pas épousé
non nous ne savions pas que nous avions une chance que votre
deuxième album true colors ait moins de
succès que le premier maintenant pourquoi
pensez-vous euh bien parce que c'était  le
deuxième ouais et parce que je ne l'ai pas
fait parce que ce qui s'est passé est ce que j'ai
naturellement été  est venu comme un truc
et je ne voulais pas faire le truc alors j'ai
tout pris et en plus de ce que je
faisais tout le monde faisait après un moment, ce qui
était bien si j'inspirais les gens à s'habiller
vous savez et à être créatifs vous savez
mais euh je  ne savais-je pas que je devais prendre du
recul et regarder cela et dire maintenant attends une
minute pour que je sache qui tu es mais qui suis-
je comme un de mes amis qui le jour où
tu es allé à des barrières de tranchées avec tes
droits de cinéma  qui n'a pas eu beaucoup de
succès à aucun
eh bien je ne pense pas que j'ai fait du mauvais travail mais le
truc d'écrivain Adam a plutôt bien réussi
en France oh ouais
ouais c'était ouais tu vois ils ne t'ont pas
invité tu vas en Russie à la fin
d'un  88 parce que j'avais déjà mixé la nuit pour
me souvenir et puis euh c'était
juste et
je devais le faire parce que je sentais que je
devais le sortir en même temps qu'un
film et dans le film les gens disaient
allez tu dois  mettre la promotion et tu
dois faire ceci tu dois faire cela et j'ai
commencé à essayer de plaire à tout le monde
et le seul  le gars qui n'était pas vraiment
content, c'était moi et à la fin,
tout le
monde n'était pas content non plus, donc je n'ai pas
écouté mon instinct, alors j'ai
tout mis de côté et l'album n'était
pas juste à ce moment-là quand ils
commencé à dire travail avec ce gars et
travail avec ce gars et ils faisaient
ces gars fait le genre de disques que
je détestais
j'ai dit regarde mes amis vont en
Russie je pense que j'aimerais y aller tu sais
parce qu'à ce moment la Sibérie serait
ça avait l'air bien imaginez que vous
avez une minute on se rencontre dans un club
comme celui-ci et vous voulez me parler de
votre dernier album le troisième et moi pour
me souvenir que me diriez-vous juste pour me le
vendre Oh à  Je te le vends je
ne sais pas je dis juste que c'est un album dont
tu te souviendras ouais